-Performing their new
single "Over,"
please welcome CHVRCHES.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-♪ Sometimes I just drive ♪
♪ Till the night
turns off my mind ♪
♪ I'm passing cars
and crowded bars ♪
♪ Never know
until I go too far ♪
♪ Confusing faith and fear ♪
♪ Paint a smile
from ear to ear ♪
♪ 'Cause if I blink,
I start to think ♪
♪ I feel nothing,
I feel everything ♪
♪ I try my best
to turn down the noise ♪
♪ And I tell myself
that boys will be boys ♪
♪ It's gettin'
harder to breathe ♪
♪ So, baby, put me to sleep ♪
♪ Till it gets better ♪
♪ So wake me up when it's over ♪
♪ It's over ♪
♪ When it's over ♪
♪ Tell me it was all
just a dream ♪
♪ And wake me up
when it's over ♪
-♪ Over ♪
-♪ It's over ♪
-♪ When it's over ♪
♪ Tell me it was all
just a dream ♪
♪ And I'll believe it ♪
♪ Keep me in the dark ♪
♪ Then fast-forward
to the part ♪
♪ With endless nights
and neon lights ♪
♪ I'll be beautiful
and starry-eyed ♪
♪ I try my best
to turn down the noise ♪
♪ And I tell myself
that boys will be boys ♪
♪ It's gettin'
harder to breathe ♪
♪ So, baby, put me to sleep ♪
♪ Till it gets better ♪
♪ So wake me up
when it's over ♪
♪ It's over ♪
♪ When it's over ♪
♪ Tell me it was all
just a dream ♪
♪ And wake me up
when it's over ♪
-♪ Over ♪
-♪ It's over ♪
-♪ When it's over ♪
♪ Tell me it was all
just a dream ♪
♪ And I'll believe it ♪
♪♪
♪ Sometimes I just drive ♪
♪ When I can't turn
off my mind ♪
♪ I don't know where ♪
♪ I'll meet you there someday ♪
♪ So wake me up
when it's over ♪
♪ It's over ♪
♪ When it's over ♪
♪ Tell me it was all
just a dream ♪
♪ And wake me up
when it's over ♪
-♪ Over ♪
-♪ It's over ♪
-♪ When it's over ♪
♪ Tell me it was all
just a dream ♪
♪ And I'll believe it ♪
[ Cheers and applause ]